>> HARDWICK: May the Fourth be
with you.
It's Star Wars Day.
(applause and cheering)
Ah!
So excited.
Feels like it comes earlier and
earlier every year, but, no, May
the Fourth.
Here it is.
Even though we're dedicating
this whole show to "Star Wars"
with "Star Wars" guests, "Star
Wars" clips, "Star Wars"
Underoos...
Bam! I'm wearing Jar Jar Spanx.
(laughter)
(applause and cheering)
Mm.
(like Jar Jar): Meesa balls
are sweaty.
(laughter)
Still, we didn't want to go
overboard.
After all, it's just some
movies, right?
Who would take "Star Wars" too
seriously?
Well, maybe a man named
JJ Abrams...
(laughter)
...who told a conference in
Beverly Hills, "'Star Wars'
isn't a movie, it's a religion."
He started to say more, but was
immediately burned at the stake
for the sin of not including Han
Solo's fuzzy dice in the
Millennium Falcon.
(laughter)
So, comedians, if "Star Wars"
is, in fact, a religion, what is
a "Star Wars" Commandment?
(Wilhelm scream)
Alan...
(laughter, applause)
It's, uh...
We've... altered the buzzers a
little bit.
>> Great. Great.
>> HARDWICK: Alan.
>> Uh, honor thy father and
mother unless your father is a
dark Sith lord, and then really,
it's a just a couple Hail Marys
and...
>> HARDWICK: Yeah. All right.
Points.
(laughter, applause)
(laser blast)
Ashley.
>> Thou shall not assume that
the Ewoks are tiny bears.
>> HARDWICK: All right, yes.
Points.
(laughter, applause)
No. You know what they are?
>> No.
>> HARDWICK: The Ewoks...
Hang on.
The Ewoks are just small,
inbred, house Wookiees.
(laughter)
Like, just someone tried to
breed a docile house Wookiee,
and so that's...
You know, they have those little
shih tzu faces.
They have, like...
(laughter)
It's like the same...
(applause)
They have all the same
congenital birth defects that
shih tzus have from just years
of inbreeding.
(laughter)
And they're terrible pets.
Oh, they try to eat you.
(laughter)
They're terrible pets.
Oh, they try to eat you.
It's like you're constantly...
They're terrible pets.
Like, the poop cakes in their
It's like you're constantly...
fur 'cause they bipedal, and
Like, the poop cakes in their
they're fully...
fur 'cause they bipedal, and
(laughter, applause)
they're fully...
And you try to clean 'em, and
(laughter, applause)
they're just, like, "Yup."
And you try to clean 'em, and
And you're like, "Yeah, I know.
they're just, like, "Yup."
Yeah, Yub Nub, I got to get to
And you're like, "Yeah, I know.
work, man.
Yeah, Yub Nub, I got to get to
Come on, chill out.
work, man.
Stop trying to put me on a
Come on, chill out.
spit."
Stop trying to put me on a
>> And make sure they're spayed
spit."
and neutered.
>> And make sure they're spayed
>> HARDWICK: Yeah, make sure
and neutered.
you spay and neuter your Ewoks.
>> HARDWICK: Yeah, make sure
(applause)
you spay and neuter your Ewoks.
Hang on.
(applause)
Can I blow your mind?
Hang on.
Wookiee, Ewok-- the same
Can I blow your mind?
letters.
Wookiee, Ewok-- the same
The same... fucking animal...
letters.
(laughter)
The same... fucking animal...
...alien, sort of.
(laughter)
>> That's...
...alien, sort of.
>> Wow.
>> That's...
>> HARDWICK: Anyway...
>> Wow.
>> Heavy.
>> HARDWICK: Anyway...
>> HARDWICK: John DiMaggio.
>> Heavy.
>> Thou shalt not worship any
>> HARDWICK: John DiMaggio.
false idols, especially that
>> Thou shalt not worship any
dick Gene Roddenberry.